I grew up in a theater family. My
father produced Shakespeare festivals.
We were all theater rats, me and my
siblings. The first time I acted on stage
I think I was about two years old. It was
my background and my father was my great
hero growing up. I mean Harvard as an
institution has never seen itself as an
arts conservatory, but you don't get into
Harvard if you don't have some
experience of the arts and, no question,
there was no studying the arts at
Harvard when I was here, but those were
the four most creative years of my life,
bar none. And of course now there's
the theater, dance, and media department. You
can get a degree for it. We created
horrible theater. I was a catastrophic
singer and yet, my god, I stopped the show
in a Gilbert and Sullivan operetta which
may just have been the very moment when
I decided to become an actor. The arts
define a culture, they define who we are.
Country music defines us absolutely as
much as a Broadway theater. There is so
much concentration on the STEM subjects
so I came up with the image of a flower.
The STEM subjects are the stem of the
flower: they service the blossom but the
arts of the blossom and they are what
define the flower. That's what gives the
flower its beauty, its identity, its
ability to reproduce itself. Young people
should keep alive their interest in the
arts for their whole lives. We all
benefit from self-expression and joy. I
mean, creative joy: there's something that
just keeps us all alive and it is so much a
part of a human being's sense of
himself or herself. I'm very flattered
when people say that I give back to the
Harvard community, but believe me it's
completely selfishly motivated.
It took me a while for it to really
dawn on me how important Harvard has
been to me because off I went into the
entertainment world, which is so
different from the Harvard world. But
since I've sort of come back to the
community and been embraced by the
community and re-embraced the community it
really has been so much a part of my life.